6 25 on your friday morning you know
what you still have a chance to have
your words
up in light all over the state let me
explain are you ready
let's go centennial
bowling
all right so there are no plans to put
in overhead signs like these
as part of this that big project where
us 95 meets the northern 215 beltway
but there are nearly 400 overhead signs
spread
all over the silver state so we're all
going to have plenty of opportunities to
see
the winning entry from the contest from
the nevada department of transportation
remember we mentioned this a few weeks
ago
just wanted to remind you the deadline
for entries is monday august 31st
so a lot of us get chuckles out of
something clever showing up on these
signs like this one don't
be a stinker use your blinker ndot
director christina swallow says
roadway signs can be a first-line
defense in reminding drivers to drive
safely
the more creative relatable and
memorable the better
a quick reminder some of the obvious
restrictions though nothing obscene no
advertising no websites no phone numbers
and yes the message does have to be
about traffic safety okay
and no more than three lines with 18
characters in each line that includes
spaces
no hashtags no punctuation no emojis you
must be 16 years old or older to enter
and you can only enter at this
n.web page nevadadot.com
sign the winners announced next month
will be rotated through some or all of
those hundreds of overhead
signs and don't you don't have to
scramble to write this down all of this
information is on our website
8newsnow.com you click traffic then
driving you crazy
buckle up drive carefully please put
down that phone
if there is something driving you crazy
email me pictures and videos too
to traffic eight at eight news now dot
com